is it seem as if so many here in Las  Vegas are no longer that concerned about  kovat 19-hour Cruz spoke to quite a few  people on the strip today some say  they're still seeing safety measures  others have noticed many people  gathering in large groups without masks  UNLV assistant public health professor  Brian lavish says our state's reopening  was designed to go along with social  distancing if everyone gives up now  things could take a turn it's probably  putting out a fire you can't stop  halfway through and expect the fire to  go away we're at that point now where  people still need to keep doing these  things even though they're annoying even  though they're frustrating even though  we're sick of doing them he added that  the virus transmission is still  happening here in Southern Nevada  remember you are still at a higher risk  every time you do go out in public you  still got to be very careful